Avengers: Endgame is filled with mindblowing
moments on a scale never before seen in cinematic
history.
But it also includes a lot of small, quiet
moments, and hidden details including one
super important cameo most fans missed.
"He's coming!"
"... who?"
It happens during the support group scene
early in the film, where Steve Rogers is shown
discussing the impact of the snap with several
other survivors, one of whom is played by
Endgame co-director Joe Russo.
But while some fans of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe were geeking out about that, they
may not have noticed that one of the other
support group members is none other than legendary
comic book writer and artist Jim Starlin,
the man who created Thanos, Gamora, and Drax
in the first place.
Credited simply as "Support group Man #1,"
Starlin opened up about his Endgame cameo
in a post on Instagram.
Though Starlin's cameo was small, his involvement
in the film at all is a big deal considering
some of the major issues he has had with Marvel
in the recent past.
In January 2017, for instance, Starlin posted
on Facebook that his royalty check for his
minor villain KGBeast appearing in Batman
v Superman was,
And in December, 2017, Starlin publicly parted
ways with the comic book branch of Marvel
as he felt editorial decisions had severely
undermined a long running Thanos project he
had been working on for the company.
But it seems as though the mutual admiration
between Starlin and brothers Joe and Anthony
Russo has smoothed over those past difficulties.
In February, 2017, Starlin posted on Facebook
that after seeing his Infinity Gauntlet tome
in the Infinity War behind the scenes short,
he was excited to see what the directors might
do with the material, adding,
To which the Russos replied,
It's almost as if appearing in a movie with
his most popular creation was Starlin's destiny.
"Dread it, run from it, destiny sarrives all
the same.
And now it's here."
Though Starlin didn't appear in Avengers:
Infinity War, he told his Facebook fans that
he was "proud" of the movie.
And he told SyFy that he was particularly
happy with Avengers: Endgame.
He also doesn't think that we've seen the
last of Thanos, regardless of how Endgame
concluded.
So, there you have it folks: the one tiny
cameo in Avengers: Endgame that slipped right
under your radar has serious ties to Marvel
and if Starlin has any sway in the decision-making
process, Thanos might return from space dust
for another Marvel movie.
Let's hope if that happens, the heroes know
to aim for his head the first time around.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.